so hey everybody had a little Mike
trouble on this one sound quality is not
going to be up to usual standard sorry
all right well 10th doctor's first
outing howdy-do
[Applause]
[Music]
so having caught all the way up on
Doctor Who series to with my overdue
Doctor Who reviews I thought I'd do
something that I actually haven't done
for old series really kind of except for
series one and that was by default which
is to rank the individual episodes of
the series I did that like when series
11 wrapped up and like said I kind ended
up doing it for series 1 because that
was the only one for Eccleston so when I
ranked knife doctor stories that was the
entire DC's series 1 but I've never
really done it on these other ones
before and was kind of interesting to
work it out now keep in mind that I
count two parters as one story so even
though there are 13 episodes altogether
this is effectively gonna be a top 10
rank I'm also leaving out Christmas
invasion I don't like to try and
integrate the the specials into these
sorts of lists this is just sticking to
the episodes that are considered series
2 and before I get into the ranking I
want to say that it boy series 2 was
uneven as heck like it has some very
high high points but boy there's a
couple of real stinkers in this one and
then a fair amount of middle ground
which honestly in some ways did remind
me a series 11 which had a handful of
episodes that I really liked a couple I
really couldn't stand and then a lot
kind of wavering in the middle I'll try
not to draw too many comparisons but I
couldn't help but point out that one so
let's start at the bottom number 10 fear
her probably not the one I want people
or were expecting I'm sure most people
would have expect me to stick loving
monsters at the bottom it's the most
hated but the thing is and I talked
about this in my episode review I can
look at love and monsters and at least
see the core of an idea that might have
worked
loving monsters I swear this is the last
comparison I'll make to series 11 is the
senton is the Suranga conundrum of
series 2 there's just nothing here
that's really any good nothing is
building like there's no part of this
that I would have gone oh well they if
they focus more on that
better like none of this is any good but
at the same time it's not good in a
highly unmemorable way which i think is
why it doesn't show up in as many like
worst episode list as it probably should
because it's not bad in a way that like
abuses you as much
but boy this thing it's really got
nothing going on moving up one slot to
number 9 it's love no it's not as idiots
Lantern and I this one I I did have I
didn't have a problem putting fear her
at the bottom but I did go back and
forth you know what should be the next
up from that because there were a number
of possibilities
the thing about idiots Lantern
especially going back and revisiting it
was catching a glimpse of a couple of
things that were decent ideas and
somehow getting more frustrated with the
episode for spotting those and realizing
the handful of things that were
squandered by the mountains of stuff
that doesn't work and then but then
having all that completely undercut by
getting to the end and seeing what I had
completely forgotten which is rose
encouraging a young man to to run to and
support and be forgiving towards his
abusive father who's literally just
stepped out of the house no I'm not
gonna read you my whole ramp up man that
really ticked me off
and even aside from that the father as a
character is cartoonish I understand
what it's trying to what the episodes
trying to do with that portrayal but
it's cartoonish and I can't take it
seriously the wire is an effective
enough villain until we get to the home
stretch where she stops being an
intimidating version of the mother of
the 50s housewife TV archetype and just
starts going me hungry over and over and
over and over again and then I frickin
don't care like a couple of good things
just get buried under the rest of this
so going up from there let's get the
last really obvious episode all the way
lovin monsters and yes I did debate
between this an idiot slander but the
difference is idiots Lantern actively
pissed me off where as low and monsters
it didn't love and monsters is weird and
bizarre and frustrating but in an odd
way kind of admirable because it's so
different from almost anything else that
dr. whoever does you can kind of look at
it as like a okay well that was an
experiment it didn't work but you know
bless your heart for trying and I can't
give that that much of a benefit of the
doubt or you know a little semi bit of a
pass to you know fear her or the idiots
or the idiots Lantern but yeah love the
monsters has got a lot going wrong
tonally it's kind of McGee R ships of
the tone don't really work and it's but
yeah what it's sort of trying to say
about fandom isn't a bad thing to base
the episode on but it's also not doing
anything aside from that it basically
just is the allegory and then isn't
really a story beyond that and the
characters aren't fleshed out and it
just it's clunky and it's weird and it's
cringy and yeah and I know it was
designed by a kid but the the monsters
embarrassing and just know it doesn't
work okay now that we've gotten the who
drags out of the way now we get to kind
of the white noise of the middle of
series 2 which is episodes that were not
awful but also like not much to write
home about starting with number 7
Neuwirth so yeah this is a really weak
first proper outing you know in this
series proper for the Tenth Doctor I
think I don't think bringing back
Cassandra was as enjoyable as Davies
thought it was I mean like she gets kind
of a nice bittersweet note at the very
end but I'm not sure that that by itself
is worth bringing her back which doesn't
really bring much to the table otherwise
the cat nuns are just there and like the
the whole plot is functional but that's
kind of just it this is functional but
it doesn't feel like a proper new
rollicking adventure it's just like oh
okay
so yeah future hospital
cat nuns got it it's very bland overall
yeah it does it just doesn't leave much
going for it really so going out from
there we get to number six which is an
episode that I actually do enjoy but
it's it's got some clunky bits which is
tooth and claw there's a handful of
things that I do actually really like
about this I like hearing David
Tennant's natural accent for a chunk of
time there's some pretty decent humour
in here the the visual effects of the
werewolf hasn't really aged very well
it's debatable how good it was even at
the time but they try what they can to
shoot around most of the time by
restricting it to shadows you know when
they can there are a couple of like hero
shots of the thing that are like yeah
but you know the what it has it is it
has a decent atmosphere actually there's
some really good music tracks on this
one but it's it's got a couple of
highlights in the depiction of Queen
Victoria it's pretty good so it's got
little things that keep it fun even as
you know that's just kind of a somewhat
rote monster in a in a period setting
Doctor Who story it gets the job done
and it's fun enough alright number five
we have our first two-parter on the list
rise of the Cybermen and the age of
Steel on this is one that I probably
would have thought better of in years
past because at the first time I saw
this I didn't have other versions of the
submarine to compare to this was my
introduction to them and I thought they
were pretty good but now that I've
gotten to know other takes on the
Cybermen from classic who from Big
Finish and then even later on down the
line and knew who different ways that
they've been done I really don't care
for this version of Cybermen too much
but setting aside my own wish for what
the Cybermen were and they just aren't
it's a decent enough story it's kind of
an interesting way to handle a parallel
earth story Pete actually turns out to
be a pretty dang good character the
villain is goofy and weird and laughable
and monologues horrendously but it does
the job well enough Mickey actually gets
some surprising poignancy here and it's
it's fun it's also this is another one
with a great music track the the the
theme music that is used for the
Cybermen actually
really like I think I like you better
than Dalek music and we're being honest
so that's that's really good stuff and
it's it has a sense of fun and just a
good amount of energy that helps kind of
smooth over the rough patches a little
bit so now we're gonna get into the
episodes that I think unequivocally
really good stuff and now I'm just
ranking my preferences out of them so
first up we at number four it's the girl
in the fireplace I suspect for a lot of
people this one probably would have been
higher it would have been their number
two or even their number one but I
mentioned it in my review I I liked it I
enjoy it
I like the mechanisms of it I like the
pacing of it I like the way it's told
for some reason this one just doesn't
have the emotional connection for me
that it wants to have and it seems to
have for a lot of other people so I
don't know if it's just something about
me but for whatever reason I don't quite
connect emotionally with this one the
way I think a lot of other people do
that said it's still really good and
really well done and the the what's
going on with the villains is an
interesting idea and the relationship
between Renetta and the doctor is really
well realized I yeah I do enjoy this
episode quite a bit it just doesn't have
the emotional linking to me that I think
a lot of other folks got out of it so
moving up to number three speaking of
emotions we get the army of ghosts and
doomsday so the two-part series finale
and yeah this one also has some
clunkiness to it not dissimilar to
something like say the previous
two-parter I mentioned with the Cybermen
but this one has really good emotional
resonance for me and that really does
help me to be forgiving about things and
not to mention I do just get into the
raucous fun of Cybermen versus Daleks
why wouldn't I want that that's just a
good time so I I'm digging all of all of
that and then you know the emotional
impact and everything going on with ROS
and being separated from the doctor and
honestly even just Jackie reuniting with
Pete works really well for me too so I
was and I was surprised that that was
a new element for me so I felt that
while it's not narrative ly the best
thing in the world I do think it has a
good strong emotional impact and it
leaves you feeling the way Russell T
Davies wanted you to feel and I think
it's very successful on that on that
front up towards the top two number two
I'm gonna put school reunion now I do
have nitpicks about this and I mentioned
it before especially as I've gotten to
know doctor who has a franchise better
I'm increasingly skeptical of the way
that they treated Sarah Jane and I don't
really love the implications that that
are kind of at play in terms of this
idea that Sarah Jane kind of you know
never really had much of a life that she
was that impressed with after she left
the doctor so it does have that baggage
that I don't love but if I look at the
things of Canaan and I myself it's
really good Sarah Jane even though she
is a wonderful piece of nostalgia even
if you don't know who she is because the
first time I ever saw this episode I
didn't works really well she's well sold
for what she's doing and why she's there
and these do her head is phenomenal as
mr. Finch I really love him as a villain
and this canine is cute Mickey has some
great moments it's I mean the whole
episode feels very Buffy the Vampire
Slayer and it's not that I would ever
want Doctor Who to feel like that
overall full-time but like for kind of a
one-off bit of a lark yeah that's a lot
of fun and and pretty decent residence
in terms of like with things like Sarah
Jane so yeah I like this one a lot but
it's not number one and I think you all
knew what number one was going to be the
impossible planet and the Satan pit I do
love me some beast um yeah I just just
about everything about this I love I you
know I acknowledge some weird goofy
aspects to it but they're short-lived
and quickly forgotten in the wake of the
astounding atmosphere of this thing -
great sense of tension the wonderful so
the threat of the beast and on both a
visceral and an existential level the
Crillon cool look for the OOD the
fantastic supporting cast which you know
are playing all these characters of feel
fully properly
fleshed out the doctor being sort of on
the back foot because he does not know
what he's dealing with but the
implications of what it might be are
throwing him off and making him
uncomfortable it's just it's just great
top to bottom
I mean I've always loved this two-parter
but I can also safely now say it's my
favorite story out of series 2 series 2
ranked how would you rank it or what's
your top what's your bottom what are
your thoughts on my ranking whatever you
think about any of this yeah just drop
your thoughts down in the comments let's
talk about it a whole bunch of other
stuff to do because there's buttons and
links including one's a patreon so you
can check that out I'll boot links
besides p.o box address and cetera check
it out if you want to if you don't
that's ok because at the end of the day
you're the council
I'm just running the meetings and until
next time this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]